sin oposición política ni Prensa libre
en Afganistán algunas mujeres han salido
a la calle pero sus manifestaciones se
responden con cañones de agua
encarcelamiento e incluso torturas por
lo que han surgido nuevas formas de
resistencia
estas tres estudiantes fundaron la
semana pasada a una comunidad en línea
en respuesta al decreto talibán sobre la
enseñanza superior su grupo ya cuenta
con 500 miembros
esta profesora de la Universidad de
kabul ha quemado sus documentos y ha de
emitido cuando nos prohibieron ir a la
universidad todos rompimos a llorar
estábamos muy tristes porque no nos
dejan estudiar que habíamos hecho lejos
de resignarse a su destino estos
estudiantes tienen ambiciones
esperanzados por el cambio está
estudiante de derecho de 22 años era una
de las mejores alumnas de su universidad
y aspira a convertirse en jueza sin
poder ir a clase sigue su trabajo en
casa
bajo el primer régimen talibán de 1996 a
2001 Todo estaba prohibido en las calles
las mujeres no podían salir sin compañía
si comparamos ese periodo con lo que
ocurre Ahora hay poca diferencia pero
hay un cambio importante ahora podemos
informar al mundo a través de las redes
sociales
esta manifestación tiene lugar en un
lugar secreto por la seguridad de los
participantes pero espera llamar la
atención de la comunidad internacional
ningún país puede funcionar sin mujeres
y niñas educadas no nos desarrollaremos
los talibanes intentan mantenernos en la
oscuridad por eso he seguido dando
clases a las jóvenes privadas de
enseñanza secundaria
a ojos de estas manifestantes solo la
presión occidental puede detener la
campaña extremista de los talibanes
contra las mujeres